[Music]
what's the best fast food chain bro what
is this what kind of bro are you bro are
you okay uh between Chick-fil-A dude
it's Gotta Be Sonic I'm gonna say
Chick-fil-A favorite bro movie of all
time Shawshank Redemption
Fight Club Big Lebowski Animal House
Shawshank Redemption is a bro movie what
yeah if you're like from the East Coast
I don't know I feel like East Coast
dudes are like yo Shawshank uh Big
Lebowski I would say I knew you're gonna
say that [ __ ] yeah I just watched it for
the first time you lazy [ __ ] I'm going
Fight Club but we'll go Big Lebowski
we'll see what kind of bro Cody is
oh
wow bro
we're at Coachella festival was this
[ __ ] written in 2008 yeah
what are you most excited about the
music the chicks the herb the herb dude
this is from 2001. I'm actually more
into Stagecoach Country Music Festival
bro
yeah I'm gonna go the herb because you
know you know me you know I like to puff
down on that sweet sandwich
just the weed the world would be better
if more Bros would just go to church
relax
the power of the mighty sec
that's Ben oh God
invest in my future in my future like if
other Bros were to invest in my future
yeah yeah lock it in
you go bowling with your Bros and score
a lane next to some hot chicks how do
you
how do you impress them yo are you guys
12.
yo you guys want to smoke cigarettes
ask them if they puff and show up
ew dude show off the herb
this is a [ __ ] super senior ass quiz
yeah you see my balls right here check
it out that's some herb right there
you brag about your job
you ladies have heard of podcasting at
all
we're 10 it's pretty big
birthday
[Laughter]
what might cause a fistfight with a
fellow bro bro
loudly rooting for the wrong team bro
touching my neck
[Laughter]
yeah exactly loudly rooting for the
wrong team kissing my neck don't fight
myself wait what bro stroking me
we just have to we have to commend this
quiz for being decades ahead of its time
yeah these are this is a tick tock
comment section yeah bro disrespecting
me lol yeah bro loudly rooting for the
wrong thing bro touching my neck
the fact that you just your reading was
perfect until that one oh it's truck
yeah dude it's bro touching my truck
just zoned out
and fantasize some [ __ ]
now look pick the neck one seriously
that's funny all right dude stop [ __ ]
around how do you get your class every
day public transport truck slash next
slash car next car
yo y'all want to take a ride in my neck
bro you want to take my neck for a ride
my bro my boy's got the dopest neck bro
pull up take my neck for a spin
oh yeah I did not it's cool
huge neck
he can fit so much in his neck
bro how many we got six it's chill let's
Pile in my neck dude just all Pile in my
neck
too bike slash walk every day nah I
don't get there every yeah that's
I don't get there every yeah that's me
now I would say bike slash walk no dude
your your next slash car
I thought we were talking about class
like back when I was [ __ ] in class
no class slash work okay okay yeah truck
slash car next slash car
dude We Gotta Buy ad space on this
oh you know what we should do
we should run ads on the Hub
all about like tiny meat and it's just
our promoting our podcast that's a good
idea it's like do you have small meat
yeah come to the smallest like the most
probably cheap too yeah they're probably
they need Avatar advertisers can you
imagine how many people who already
listen are like cranking that's like
they click through they're like dude
but I'm thinking about you guys it's
weird yeah yeah
that's what we link to it's a video of
us being like you jacking off yeah
how's it going all right lens dude
are you jacking off you're jacking off
four dollars for a thousand pairs of
eyeballs so that's what it is
sit there are 27 cents per thousand
Impressions wow let's go let's [ __ ]
go off man
we should try this
we gotta I mean we gotta like hack
marketing a little bit we got to do some
sultry looking ads too
do you have small meat yeah get a girl
from a stock photo site
yeah all right you're all set hot
podcasts in your area yeah yeah yeah
hot podcasters in your area yeah
just us
that's [ __ ] funny dude yeah guys are
in your area yeah easy
you're all set for an afternoon of
growing out with your Bros what are you
guys doing next yeah piling in my neck
watching TV pre-gaming with some
microbrews
yeah it's a local IPA
watching college football and getting
drunk
or as a microbrew is a really tiny beer
yeah
nice
that's cheers wait shock on it
watching college football and getting
drunk having a smoke and playing some
video games
I mean as much as I like
having a smoke really think about this
probably pre-gaming with some microbrews
no there's a micro bruise slang for like
a small friend
like a that's my micro brute yeah yeah
that's my micro brew Cody
I'm five foot eight dude stop saying
that nah dude still microbrews are
always welcome
so mean
you are a banker bro you understand that
the true source of a bro's power is in
his wallet and you are eager to put all
those fraternity ties to you why is this
very accurate why is this very when
you're not pre-gaming for a night of
overpriced cocktails with a six pack of
overpriced microbrews
you can probably be found brown-nosing
your boss because cash money
guilty as charged
you never Brian was me dude
do you want me to Brown knows me dude